institution exists to keep the
government from what taking over your
rights taking your rights
supposed to protect your god-given
rights well yet democrats are now
opening fire on many of them including
the second amendment
yesterday the nra warned that sources in
d.c report that congress will be voting
on biden's extreme gun control
legislation
as early as next week what's in this
supposedly extreme piece of legislation
here to help us walk through it is awr
hawkins breitbart's second amendment
correspondent
awr tell us what is in this horror show
of a
piece of legislation you know certainly
laura
well you've got universal background
checks as you know
introduced today by senator chris murphy
you have
an expansion of the time it will take to
do an
instant background check that could be
expanded indefinitely
it will definitely be expanded to no
fewer than 10 days
under house whip clyburn's bill which
is als has awesome but then you have
bills by
representative sheila jackson lee h.r
we're going to put this up awr i'm going
to interrupt you we're going to put up
the bullet so people can follow what
you're saying here
okay here's what's in her bill psych
evaluations
and licensing gun owners must report
where their firearm
is stored registration of all firearms
and ammo that's a huge uh
and create a database of registration
info
what are the gun owners of the united
states how many are
are there 80 million gun owners in the
united states and is that right
uh what are they going to say about
where you're storing your guns and
registering
ammunition right and well there are over
400 million guns in the u.s i think 432
is the last estimate so there are quite
a few gun owners out there if you back
it up from there but
you know the problem with those bills
from sheila jackson lee laura
if you keep reading into it as i know
you've done
you know she also requires she requires
liability insurance
that you pay the government for and if
you don't pay the government the 800
for liability insurance boom they take
away the right for you to own the guns
and ammo that you have registered so
they know you have them
and you will have to hand those over so
this bill
is full of trap door after trap door
it's very insidious
uh awr we're just scratching the surface
we're going to go into this
uh at length and more in depth later in
this week
thank you so much for giving us a sneak
peek